again
Ghost Recon wildlands is a squad based
Tom Clancy game that plays by the
numbers it stays true to the series
Rainbow six inspired routes emulating
the cold and calculated nature of
organized infiltration and coordinated
stealth kills unfortunately the
adherence to the specific kind of
gameplay gets lost and diluted in wild
lands as vast expanse of Bolivia a
revenge tale disguised as a narco-state
destabilization operation is low-hanging
fruit worse yet the narrative
perpetuates the notion that a cartel is
only worth taking seriously when one of
your own has been tortured today
ignoring the thousands of locals who
suffered similar fates it's easy to tell
that Karen Bowman your CIA field handler
has a personal vendetta against the
Santa Blanca a drug cartel that rules
Bolivia when you ultimately come
face-to-face with El sueño their cartels
kingpin you can spot the payoff a mile
away at the end there's no poignant
message or lesson regarding this latest
Tom Clancy episode in American
interventionism target on my back
waiting for someone else could come to
the crown the pursuit of a single lead
that Karen provides conveniently results
in a series of other clues and each one
of those tip-offs blossoms into others
enough successful missions eventually
results in confrontations with under
bosses and lieutenants who are less than
six degrees away from El sueño some of
your Intel will reveal locations of
weapons to add to your collection
so amassing a stockpile of firearms is
purely optional compared to the
multitude of games where the acquisition
of guns is a major selling point
wild lines of selection is serviceable
the problem is that you can easily
complete the game with your initial
loadout where the fans who've been
hooked on Ghost Recon for the advancing
technologies the lack of gadgetry and
wildlands will prove this appointing the
novel appeal of drones has long since
expired well you can upgrade it with a
handful of offensive and diversionary
capabilities its default function as a
target marking device is all you need
while the drone marks your targets it's
your squads responsibility to pull off
the kills the need for coordination
underscores the team-based appeal of
wildlife which can be experienced with a
I control teammates or preferably with
other players when playing with skilled
friends
comfort in knowing that you'll most
likely be on the same page
playing with AI has its own benefits
like being better bullet sponges when
they're out in the open Healing you one
puzzling omission to multi player is the
ability to form a mixed squad of friends
in AI if you're only playing with one
buddy you're stuck as a pair wildlands
is most gratifying moments come from
playing the ghost it means having the
patience to spend minutes surveying a
stronghold from a distance and arming
yourself with that visual information to
confidently infiltrate the base equally
thrilling other moments where you have
little time to adapt to changing
circumstances when the best laid plans
go wrong when you've been spotted and a
base is on high alert you're treated to
one of the few instances where your
squad mates moment to moment updates are
actually useful when a high-value target
is fleeing your team will let you know
at the outset it appears that wild lines
of strength is in its diverse mission
types for every assassination there's a
capture or rescue assignment you might
even find yourself pulling off the old
switcharoo with two similar looking
trucks group I got no idea who that is
don't [ __ ] me Hernando you had to
tell me where I can find Reed or I make
sure El sueño knows all about your
little human trafficking rings it's
never a dull moment at least for the
first 20 or so hours by the time you've
experienced these kinds of objectives a
handful of times boredom sets in the mix
of dense vegetation and barren mountains
of Bolivia echo the environments of
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain just
less accommodating navigating your way
down a rocky cliff on foot is as
unpredictable as climbing one instead
you're left using vehicles as your most
reliable means of traversal yet for a
map that should be more off-road
friendly this interpretation of Bolivia
often Courage's you to keep to the
beaten path
lest you wipeout after a sick cliff jump
on a motorcycle as only the second
open-world game in the clan severs Ghost
Recon wildlands is a middling Lee safe
tactical shooter with a slightly wasted
opportunity given the ambitious scope of
its seemingly boundless map while its
main strength is its mission diversity
it doesn't take long to lose the
motivation after reaching El sueño
doorstep even with a foursome of
highly-trained friends wild lads
eventually reveals its demented
in return the feeling of positive
immediacy and dopamine hits begins to
wane sooner than you expected from a
game with such a large and diverse world
[Music]